i just okay cause i think of all the
people that let this happen yeah the
coach
the coach the administration like
there's so many people that had to let
this happen i'm like
what
this is crazy
oh my god
i would not want that
i would not want him in my changing room
i'm sorry i wouldn't i would feel weird
it's like essentially
so you're telling me the difference
between that those two pictures so he
was on top and yeah he was on top and
about him and essentially
um
the difference between those two
pictures is short hair he was a man long
hair he's a woman
and i guess his is a little it's like
not even feminine
like does that look like a girl to you
no
i'm gonna get you guys cancelled
this might be the broadcast to do it
there are some there are some women who
have manly features as well yeah that's
what i was gonna say yeah
you know i'm i'm thinking of a couple
and i still think even the girls with
manly features
if
if i if i knew if i was a man
and i was a sketchy one i'm not saying
that she is i was a schedule and i was
athlete and i'm like okay i'm good i'm
good at men's sports but i'm not that
great if i didn't have
no more conscious
i would do it i'd be like oh i'm
transitioning and dominate women's
sports and then after i do what i need
to do in that and get whatever money i
need to change my mind i actually want
to de-transition and just go back and be
like
and i'm not saying and like me saying
that i can i can feel like someone's
gonna be like that's disrespectful blah
blah blah was just like
if it
if that's if that's all it takes it's
just to take uh i know estrogen i know
taking hormone pills is a lot but if
there's no if i can get in cahoots with
a doctor with people and say hey like
when i make my money i'm gonna pay you
off so if someone comes if a new
reporter asks if they need physical
evidence that i am transitioning to a
woman provided for them and i got you
i'll pay you off once i get all this
money
and i may i may just have god gave
someone just gold right there
well and and it's like for narcissists
like who would
because i i've talked to tran like trans
people that agree they're like no why on
earth would we be in that league what
what typically yeah no there's like like
blair wool
[Music]
um
but like
and even caitlyn jenner like she says
that oh no like we should not be allowed
in those leagues why why is it that like
it's like the
like i honestly think a rational trans
person like really would agree and would
understand but like it's like the ones
that have to be the center like i feel
like he wants to be the center of
attention like he knew when he switched
over he would win the league he knew
he'd be the center of attention like i i
don't
i just can't
even assume good intent like i don't
believe he had good intentions because i
don't understand how you can be next to
like this girl
and genuinely look yourself in the
mirror and think that's fair
yeah did you see the picture where
uh she was on the first podium and like
everybody else was on like the third
podium i don't know the story behind it
um
but it was essentially like they were
saying
in my in my opinion that i was like oh
like
we're not even like near this person
and physically and so it's just like
we're just gonna automatically be third
because that's how that's how it's
always going to be it's like
we're never going to be first unless
she
i don't even know if
if it came to a point where they were
leah is her name leo or lisa leah leah
is physically
out of shape to where that sh some uh
biological women be able to beat her
it's like
the wingspan in swimming your your
arm length is
something that is if you got it if you
got long orangutan arms you are going to
dominate and swim because
that's what you use your arms and your
legs yeah and so
and then like look at like this coach
right here how can how can the coach
like coach how does he look like kind of
unethical
but the coach could
and the coach could also be benefiting
from this
get a stipend oh you you're one of the
first
coaches to allow trans women to swim wow
we want to give you this we want to give
you that and there's like there's perks
with having i'm not calling her when i
say this i'm not calling her this but
there's perks with having a new shiny
toy or something new like oh attention
is currency yeah like oh new okay let's
publicity news uh
news reporters being on um
news shows being on
podcasts being on whatever and having
people talk about it and people googling
and searching your name the situation
it's like it's generating stuff and
people are going to want to come and
talk to you about the situation so there
was
definitely
some perk with that coach allowing that
to happen
i just like he's grown ass man like
i just like can't i'm like you get out
there and swim against her
you go swim coat you have to be a beta
ass dude to allow this like i'm sorry
you if as a man
like i you can i don't know how you can
look yourself in the mirror and train
this grown dude do you think he even
truly respects from women's sport as a
coach though
like he can't yeah yeah even that's a
great question
do you think our coach would allow that
i don't think he would i don't think he
would i think he'd like
we do be low on numbers
oh my god